[Music]
harnessing the power of data is key to
the success of organizations and in
today's fast-faced landscape
organizations need to immediately react
to data developers need a way to get
real-time applications in production
quickly update continuously and reach
millions and billions of users with zero
downtime today I'm excited to show you
how you can use Google Cloud platform
Technologies to build applications and
systems that can react quickly to
provide real-time insights
my name is Vidya nagarajan and I lead
product management on Google cloud in
today's session I hope to show you how
you can leverage our serverless and
orchestration products to rapidly build
applications that react to events in
near real time without managing a server
we think it is the future and there is
no better way to learn about this than
directly from our customers I'm excited
to kick off the session with a guest
Antoine castex Enterprise architect at
L'Oreal Antoine will talk about how his
team was able to use serverless compute
and analytics to deliver customized and
inclusive Beauty experiences over to you
Antoine thank you so much Vijaya for the
invitation it's a very big pleasure for
me to be there with you and all the
attendees but before speaking with you
in details about the implementation let
me introduce very quickly some some
keywords about L'Oreal
L'Oreal is a 100 years old company with
90 000 people working in more than 50
countries all over the world
most important fact is the ambition of
L'Oreal the ambition is create the new
the beauty that moves the world and it
is very important for you that even if
L'Oreal is not and will be never a
nighty company it's a tech company and
that's the reason why we are still today
the first number one cosmetic beauty
company over the world
so now how we manage this the complexity
of implementing a data warehouse in
serverless
the complexity is synchronization
between different data coming from
internal coming from external data
sources across organization retail
e-commerce all the different sources
that we can have this means a very very
large footprint in terms of complexity
in terms of sustainability and at the
end that's the result is also a vendor
specific process because of different
language different technology
let me tell you the non-negotiable
principle that we have
and they are very very simple first is
the developer experience because again
our company is not an I.T company we
want to let the developer focus on the
Insight of the data and not on the
infrastructure that's why we'll say no
Ops because we don't want to manage that
secondly the even driving architecture
which is very very important we are in
the future and the future is starting
now so the architecture shows that
Humane are very important for that in
terms of scalability for the future and
at the end the security and the
sustainability security with the zero
trans principle for example with the
single sign-on and the sustainability
based on pay-as-you-go model
now let's talk about the architecture
himself
the architecture that we have chose
choose is very simple and you can see it
right now but the most important stuff
you have to remember is the elt instead
of the classic ETL that you have
certainly see a lot of time before
ETL was you transform the data before
loading it into your data warehouse elt
is now you push the data as fast as
possible in his raw format without any
modification and you do the
transformation later on the data
warehouse which is here bigquery the
serverless data analytics Solutions of
Google cloud and based on that if you
need additional feature additional
transformation and stuff like that we
use cloud run because in cloudron you
can take any container any library that
you need to do everything what is
possible
based on that we also use event Arc to
trigger event based on different event
that we have choose and workflow to
orchestrate all the different queries
and modifications that we want to do on
the data
at the end what's the result of that the
result of that is a huge amount of data
in terms of storing the storage of this
data house represent hundreds of
terabytes and we process more than 20
terabytes per month the data is coming
from as I said before multiple and
different sources
that results in a lot of data set data
set and tables and all these things are
coming into bigquery a non-demand
processing data warehouse where you only
pay for what you use and again it's the
same for Clarence so that's a very big
news for you at the end we also improve
the developer experience because now
everybody share the same ways of working
speaking one only language which is the
SQL
so for the conclusion let's let me speak
with you about the carbon footprint
because the sustainability is very
important for oer and not only for the
company but also for is customer
you have the carbon footprint of Google
Cloud here to help you to measure your
monitor and let you make some decision
you have the collaboration picker which
is also here to let you choose the best
version based on what you need
at the end that's make you takes the
best decision in terms of architecture
because remember what I said the Choose
You Will Made will will change for the
future your application and the
experience of your customer and at the
end all of this initiatives are part of
the L'Oreal for the future program which
is not only an I.T program but mainly an
Enterprise program so thank you thank
you so much for being here and back to
your video thank you Antoine now let's
discuss the programmable cloud
as you've just seen from L'Oreal our
serverless and orchestration products
Empower developers to rapidly build
applications that react to events
without having to manage a server
L'Oreal was able to rapidly build a
business critical platform by
effortlessly connecting multiple
Services driving business insights at
High Velocity we call this use of
Technologies to connect services
effortlessly in order to deliver Data
Insights and drive business
transformation their programmable cloud
at this point I hope you're asking how
do I leverage this event-driven approach
it helps to First understand the types
of service integration patterns that you
can Implement on Google Cloud
asynchronous event-driven patterns like
what we saw with L'Oreal's Beauty Tech
platform makes it possible to respond to
triggers or events when this happens
then do that to enable this pattern
developers can use event Arc to trigger
any compute such as Cloud functions
Cloud run or a workflow that executes a
combination of Google Cloud third-party
and custom services
synchronous extensions argument the
existing functionality of other gcp
services for example developers can use
cloud functions as part of a bigquery
SQL query with the new remote
user-defined functions that integrate
data analysis and Reporting with complex
procedural code and business logic
now let's double click into asynchronous
event-driven patterns with event Arc
I'll first talk about the destinations
that event Arc supports event Arc is
Google Cloud platform's event bus that
allows you to asynchronously deliver
events from within and outside of Google
and sends them to destinations including
Cloud run Cloud functions workflows and
we recently added support for gke and
are continuing to add more
I'll now double click into the sources
we want to make it easy for developers
by connecting anything to everything
within Google Cloud platform we allow
you to connect events from over 125 gcp
Services we recently added over five
third-party event sources including
Firebase extension events and are
continuing to build even more in
addition to connecting anything to
everything we want to further Delight
developers by integrating and automating
services using cloud workflows and Cloud
scheduler you can combine Loosely
coupled Services into automated
event-driven solution
Cloud tasks allows you to offload
heavyweight processes to a task queue to
run asynchronously to improve
application responsiveness
we recently announced new workflows
features like parallel steps event Arc
triggers and serverless connectors to
workspace
that open up even more new use cases for
Automation and faster data analysis and
processing
now that we've spent some time talking
about asynchronous patterns let's touch
base on synchronous patterns these
patterns are powered by Cloud functions
and argument existing functionality of
other gcp services for example we just
went GA with bigquery remote functions
here Cloud functions as part of a
bigquery SQL query can call out to other
gcp services and external apis thereby
enriching analytics data similarly with
blocking functions where Cloud functions
extend the identity platform you can
prevent a user from authenticating if
they don't meet certain criteria
I'll now take you through a quick demo
to see this all in action let's see an
example of asynchronous event driven
transformation inspired by L'Oreal
let's say we are a mass toy manufacturer
that sells to toy stores and we have
data from two different sources Source a
and Source B we want to solve a number
of problems before we bring that data
into bigquery the data structure between
the sources are different for example
the store column name is customer name
in a and store name in b
we want to check if addresses in the
column address are valid
data source B also has extra columns
that we want to remove
there is duplicate data in both the
sources
let's now review the architecture
we want to drop the files from Source a
and Source B into a cloud storage Bucket
from here we want the newly uploaded
files to trigger a workflow via event
Arc that executes functions in a
particular order to transform the data
this is an Uber workflow it will first
determine which data source the file is
coming from if it is Source a workflow a
will run if it is Source B workflow B
will run
we have Cloud functions that rename the
columns verifies the address and reaches
the column with a unique customer ID
data source V follows a similar flow but
there is an extra step to remove the
columns that we do not need and both of
them write to bigquery
we've already created and deployed the
functions mentioned earlier and we have
also have our workflow set up
the workflow at the bottom is the Uber
workflow and we have a workflow for each
data source A and B
let's now look at the Uber workflow
first we initialize the URLs so these
are the services we want to call then we
log the event that we are receiving from
event to Arc
then we switch depending on the file
name if it is from data source a we run
workflow a and if it is data source B we
run workflow B
then we will call either workflow A or B
based on the bucket name information you
can see it visualized on the right side
there is a step to determine if it is
Source A or B then we will log it and
then run it by the way you can also run
workflows in parallel
next let's look at creating the event
Arc trigger that detects the file being
dropped in cloud storage let's call this
trigger data sources then we can choose
an event provider we support over 125
sources from Google cloud and
third-party sources such as datadog we
can easily search and select cloud
storage as the event provider what's
awesome about event Arc is that you can
filter on top of cloud storage we will
choose the finalize event which is the
one for new files being dropped in we
select the correct cloud storage bucket
account
we will choose a service account that we
already have
as you can see event Arc has many
targets available these include Cloud
run gke workflows and Cloud functions we
go ahead and choose workflows and select
the Uber workflow
and we click create the trigger gets
created
we can go to our cloud storage bucket
and upload the files from the two
sources
I will upload a file from Source a wait
for that to complete and then add a file
from Source B
now when we go to bigquery under our
projects we see a data set for our
collectible toys
and when we click into final we see the
final table first we see the schema with
the standardized naming across both data
sources and we also see the customer ID
column added
when we click into preview we see the
final combined data the customer ID is
added the columns have been standardized
data has been deduplicated and the
addresses are all valid thank you
I hope you found this session helpful
and thank you Antoine for being with us
here we look forward to having you
Leverage The programmable Cloud to give
your customers the most personalized
data-driven experiences do you try out
the new features we release to
accelerate the time to value for
applications that you create and manage
you can scale up infinitely and
integrate signals events and
intelligence easily to drive business
transformation thank you again and I
hope you enjoy the rest of next
foreign